♪ ♪ ♪
- 120 mide pommes de terre sortt
de chez Patates Dolbec
tous les ans. La pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre a forcé
de l'empaquetage dès 2016,
au coût de 12 millions
de dollars.
Depuis deux ans, Hugo d'Astl'ie
artificielle pour trier
ses pommes de terre.
HUGO d'ASTOUS, directeur
général, Patates D- Certai- Cers
en vie si on n'avait pas fait
la modernisation en 2016.
Et si on n'avait pas intégré
on ne serait plus en affaires.
Et maintenant, si on n'avait pas
intégré cette technologie-là,
oui, effectivement, on serait
présentement dans le recrutement
de notre main-d'oeuvre.
- Cette technologie,
c'est une série de caméras
grâce à une banque de 30 000
photos de pommes de terre.
Elles sont ensuite triées
grâce aux algorithmes dans
selon leurs qualités
et leurs défauts.
- Lorsque les patates passent
dans la machine, elle prend
- L'intelligence artificielle
ins besoin des 30 ans
d'expérience de Nathalie
Frenette. Elle enseigne
défauts plus spécifiques
pour des clients plus exigeants.
trieur optique, Patates Dolbec
- Il ne faut pas a
d'erreurs dans les grosseurs.
Les qualités, bien, il faut
en transformation, si ça va
pour un client qui est sévère.
- Le tri automatique affiche
maintenant un taux mais néce mas
une supervision humaine.
Il faudra attendre quelques
années avant d'atteindre
l'object
- On vise, en phase un,
de passer à un trieur par table
à trier par quart de travail.
qu'on va réussir à éliminer
totalement les trieurs.
HUGUES FOLTZ, vice-président
exécutif, Vooban peur.
La première question qui était
sur toutes les lèvres il n'y a
pas si longtemps, c'est :
"La technologie vaoi?". Aujourd,
on n'est plus là pantoute.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'entreprise d'automatisation
de Patates Dolbec voit
dans l'agroalimentaire
un marché prometteur.
La main-d'oeuvre, non seulement
la dépense la plus élevée
des maraîchers. U
selon Hugues Foltz, qui accuse
un retard technologique.
survivront, c'est soit
les entri auront
forcément beaucoup innové
ou malheureusement peut-être
par des entreprises étrangères
nt rentré de nouvelles
technologies.
- C'est difficile d'êtreen affa,
mais de trouver les projets
maintenant qui voné dans cinq
à six ans, bien, il faut déjà
travailler sur ces projets-là.
- Encore coûteuse,
l'intelligence artificielle
semble nécessaire pour affronter
la concurrence de demain,les pl,
Radio-Canada, Sai